this is the University of Leeds driving
simulator it's a fully motion based
simulator so it's the most advanced of
its kind in the UK in this study we were
looking at whether or not people
understand the behavior of the automated
vehicle when it's an automation it means
that basically it will keep to that
speed limit you will stay in the center
of the lane and at that point they can
take their hands off the steering wheel
their foot off the gas and then it will
drive for them but then in some
situations the vehicle in front of them
might break quite suddenly and in that
situation they have to basically decide
whether the automation can take care of
it
or if they have to take control to go
fit in really with this we basically
show that when people are not on
physical control of the driving then
they start to lose attention and they
need that kind of physical control and
monetary to understand when they have to
be in control otherwise they'll work and
so the challenge really is making sure
that the system understands the humans
capabilities and we as humans understand
that systems capabilities and then it
works really well
so the challenge I think is for the next
10 years or so is to get to that that
point then there'll be a great thing to
have